hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a candy crush soda saga level 4 75
commentary walkthrough with some tips
this is a level of a lot of people have
asked about in the group and a lot of
people have been stuck on unfortunately
there's not a great like you know super
strategy for it it's it's sort of one of
those ones that some may be pretty good
bored and you know it's good for
frustrating but I picked I picked up a
couple things when I was playing it so
I'll let you know what some things to
think about in the beginning it's pretty
straightforward the main thing we want
to do is clear out the ice that's
blocking the center so that we can make
better combinations and really that's
what we're going to try to do the whole
time is to make combos in this space we
have as you can see the really thick
icing below where we're at and we need
to clear that out sometimes there's a
bear right behind it sometimes they're
not so you need to pay attention to that
but either way getting it out of the way
is you know big part of what we need to
do and the other thing about this level
is really using sprinkle shell to them
to the best to your best advantage and
that's often going to be using him for
the colors that are in those odd spaces
at the bottom to sort of clear things
out but you can see like for the side
columns you know those kind of get
cleared I mean that's this really kind
of tricky space but those get cleared
out through regular gameplay and so here
you know we're just looking the Blues
are in the bottom it's always good to
use blue if it's if it's effective
because it'll recharge him faster and
then we're going to look around and see
if we can set up like if I'm actually
the red going up we'll be able to make a
we would have been able to make a thing
coming down but I didn't like the jumble
of colors there so I wanted to get a
cascade and we got a you know a red fish
out of the deal
we got a color bomb up top it's kind of
out of the way so I'm not really gonna
really going to do anything with that
right this second that was when I was
making this I forgot about that I am I
got a little bit of a misclick there I
was trying to make a I'm trying to make
a Rab candy and I got pretty pretty
upset and then the guy was going to be
able to finish but it worked out anyway
so but if you're wondering why didn't
make it it wasn't because I didn't see
it it was because literally I was trying
to do it and I got it and it clicked
miss click click the wrong thing so
sprinkles charged up work and we use
them for our you know will it be the
most effective I picked them red because
of the top part ever dropped the color
bomb down a little bit and also clear
out that ice on the left and you can see
by clearing out that metal quick it puts
us in a good position to set up some
combos now they don't always come that
easy I played several times where I did
you know I kind of fought the whole way
but that's still the best strategy to
use alright so the bear at the bottom
was turned to the side that's a big
that's big help we don't want to worry
about that middle column anymore so now
we have ten moves and we're in a pretty
good spot we have the I got the fish
that's behind the ice popped out so i'll
be able to use that with the collar bomb
that'll clear things out pretty good and
I'm just kind of like trying to drop in
some more blues maybe but when we kind
of like when I count them I see that I
have about as many blue candies on the
board as I have pieces I so it's it's
pretty pretty good time just go ahead
and fire this off so we have a couple
moves left to clean things up if any to
which would probably
well alright and since that was blue it
also it also set up sprinkle porous I
think I think orange would be a fine
match making the bomb first or the rap
Kenny first is fine too but yeah we'll
use him through the orange free that
bear at the top that's left and then
that drops the green down so that we can
match that wrapped candy and that is the
last bear so basically that's what it
looks like when things go the right way
that is the strategy um you know like I
keep an eye out on that bear at the
bottom so you don't keep pounding at the
middle if you don't need to and you know
in general once you start to get like 11
or 12 bears start to look at where
they're at and you know plan accordingly
it's easy to get frustrated and just
keep doing the same things over and over
again but if you plan things out and you
get the middle gets a couple nice combos
in the middle you'll get through it
before too long I hope this helped
please like the video please subscribe
to my channel so that you get the new
ones when they come out as soon as they
come out and check back up check back
often because we make new ones all the
time I'll talk to you soon